‏be
‏no
morec
year so somebody ask you can i get one
they have show up in person
to in do are as
as per boes
back last but not least we do appreciate
you guys correcting
‏in in front please because ites a for
some us even for me i'm not leading even
for me to figure out what exactly went
wrong so just just be kind enough to us
please just too many noises we he for
correction so just leave it up here
there a problem come talk to somebody
fix it
afters all
right no no no no
‏g
[Silence]
ء
والله جزاك الله خير
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استقيم اعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والى مدين اخاهم
شعيبا قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من
اله غيره قد
جاءتكم بينه من
ربكم فاوفوا الكيل والميزان ولا تبخسوا
الناس
اشياءهم ولا تفسدوا في الارض بعد
اصلاحها ذلكم خير لكم ان
كنتم
مؤمنين ولا تقعدوا بكل صراط توعدون وتصدون
عن سبيل الله من امن به
وتبغون
عوجا واذكروا اذ كنتم قليلا فكثركم
وانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المفسدين وان كان
طائفه امنوا بالذي ارسلت به
وطائفه لم
يؤمنوا وان كان
طائفه منكم امنوا بالذي ارسلت به وط
طائفه لم
يؤمنوا فاصبروا حتى يحكم الله بيننا وهو
خير
الحاكمين قال الملا الذين استكبروا من
قومه
لنخرجنك يا
شعيب
لنخرجنك يا شعيب والذين امنوا معك او لتع
ون في
ملتنا قال الملا الذين استكبروا من قومه
لنخرجنك يا شعيب والذين امنوا معك من
ارضنا او
لتعودن في
ملتنا من قريتنا او
ملتنا قال ولو كنا
كارهين قد افترينا على الله كذبا ان عدنا
في ملتكم بعد اذ نجانا الله
منها وما يكون لنا ان نعود فيها الا ان
يشاء الله
ربنا وسع ربنا كل شيء
علما على الله
توكلنا ربنا افتح بيننا وبين قومنا بالحق
وان خير
الفاتحين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه لئن
اتبعتم شعيبا انكم اذا
لخاسرون فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم
جاثمين الذين كذبوا شعيبا كان لم يغنوا
فيها الذين كذبوا شعيبا كانوا هم
الخاسرون فتولى عنهم وقال يا قوم لقد
ابلغتكم رسالات ربي ونصحت
لكم ونصحت لكم فكيف
على قوم
كافرين وما ارسلنا في قريه من نبي
الا الا اخذنا اهلها
بالباساء
والضراء لعلهم
يضرعون ثم بدلنا مكان السيئه الحسنه حتى
حتى عفوا وقالوا قد مس
اباءنا
السراء
والضراء وقالوا قد مس
اباء انا
الضراء
والسراء
فاخذناهم
بغته وهم لا
يشعرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سميع
الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم الس ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
عل
‏pass
‏jag
[Silence]
‏v
‏sk
[Silence]
‏ser
‏k
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدلوا
استووا سوي الصف سد الخلل
استووا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولو ان اهل الكتاب امنوا واتقوا
لكفرنا عنهم
سيئاتهم لفتحنا عليهم بركات من
السماء والارض ولكن
كذبوا ولو ان اهل القرى امنوا واتقوا
لفتحنا عليهم بركات من
السماء والارض ولكن
كذبوه ولكن كذبوا
فاخذناهم بما كانوا يكسبون
افامن اهل القرى ان ياتيهم باسنا بياتا
وهم
نائمون اومن اهل القرى ان ياتيهم باسنا
ضحى وهم
يلعبون افامنوا مكر الله فلا يامن مكر
الله الا القوم الخاسر
اولم يهد للذين يرثون الارض من بعد اهلها
انو نشاء اصبناهم
بذنوبهم ونطبع على قلوبهم فهم لا
يسمعون تلك القر نقص عليك من
انباء ولقد
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينه
فما كانوا ليؤمنوا بما كذبوا من قبل كذلك
يطبع الله على قلوب
الكافرين وما وجدنا
لاكثرهم من عهد وان
وجدنا وان وجدنا اكثرهم
لفاسقين ثم بعثنا من بعدهم موسى بايات نا
الى فرعون
وملاه فظلموا بها وكانوا
قوم فظلموا بها فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المجرمين فظلموا بها فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المفسدين وقال موسى يا فرعون اني رسول من
رب العالمين
حقيق على الا اقول على الله الا
الحق قد
جئتكم
ببينه من
ربكم فارسل معي بني
اسرائيل قال ان كنت جئت بايه فات بها ان
كنت من
الصادقين فالقى عصاه اذا هي ثعبان مبين
ونزع يده فاذا هي بيضاء
للناظرين قال الملا من قوم فرعون ان هذا
لساحر
عليم يريد ان
يخرجكم من ارضكم بسحره فماذا
تامرون قالوا ارجه واخاه ارسل في
المدائن
حاشرين ياتوك بكل ساحر
عليم وجاء السحره فرعون قالوا ان لنا
لاجرا ان كنا نحن
الغالبين قال نعم
وانكم لمن
المقربين قالوا يا موسى اما
تلقي واما ان نكون نحن
الملقين قال القوا
فلما القوا سحروا اعين الناس واسترهبوهم
وجاءوا بسحر عظيم واوحينا الى
موسى واوحينا الى موسى ان الق عصاك فاذا
هي قف ما
يافكون فوقع الحق وبطل ما كانوا
يعملون فغلبوا هنالك
وانقلبوا
صاغرين والقي السحره
ساجدين قالوا امنا برب
العالمين رب موسى
وهارون قال فرعون
امنتم به قبل ان اذن لكم ان هذا لمكر
مكرتموه في المدينه
لتخرجوا لتخرجوا منها اهلها فسوف
تعلمون
لاقطعن ايديكم وارجلكم من خلاف
ثم
لاصلبنكم اجمعين
قالوا انا الى ربنا
منقلبون وما تنقم منا الا ان امنا بايات
ربنا لما
جاءتنا ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا
وتوفنا
مسلمين وقال الملا من ق فرعون اتذر وقال
وقال الملا من قوم فرعون اتذر موسى وقومه
اتذر موسى وقومه ليفسدوا في الارض ويذرك
والهتك قال سنقتل
ابناءهم
ونستحيي
نساءهم
وان انا فوقهم
قاهرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين قال موسى لقومه استعينوا بالله
واصبروا ان الارض لله يورثها من
يشاء من عباده والعاقبه
للمتقين قالوا اوذينا من قبل ان تاتينا
ومن بعد ما جئتنا
قال عسى ربكم ان يهلك عدوكم
ويستخلفكم في الارض
ويستخلفكم في الارض فينظر كيف
تعملون ولقد اخذنا ال فرعون بالسنين ونقص
من الثمرات
ونقص من الثمرات
لعلهم يذكرون
اذا
جاءتهم الحسنه قالوا لنا هذه وان تصبهم
سيئه
يطير بموسى ومن
معه الا
انما
طائركم عند الله
ولا الا انما ط الا ان طا
م عند
الله الا انما
طائركم عند
طائرهم عند الله ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعقلون
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون واذا جاءتهم الحسنه قالوا لنا هذه
وان تصبهم سيئه يطيروا بموسى ومن
معه الا انما
طائرهم عند الله ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وقالوا مهما تاتنا به من ايه
لتسحرنا
فما نحن لك
بمؤمنين فارسلنا عليهم الطوفان والجراد
والقمل
والقمل والضفادع والدم ايات
مفصلات فاستكبروا وكانوا قوما
مجرمين ولما وقع عليهم القول الرجز قالوا
يا موسى
ولما وقع عليهم الرجز قالوا يا موسى ادع
لنا ربك بما عهد عندك لئن كشفت عنا الرجز
لنؤمنن لك ولنر السلن معك بني
اسرائيل فلما كشفنا عنهم الرجز الى اجل هم
بالغوه اذا هم ينكثون
فانتقمنا منهم
فاغرقناهم في اليم بانهم كذبوا باياتنا
وكانوا عنها
غافلين واورثنا القوم الذين كانوا
يستضعفون مشارق الارض
ومغاربها واورثنا القوم الذي كانوا
يستضعفون مش ارق الارض و
ومغاربها وتمت كلمه ربك الحسنا على بني
اسرائيل بما
صبروا واورثنا القوم الذين كانوا يستضعفون
مشارق الارض ومغاربها التي باركنا فيها
وتمت كلمه ربك الحسنى على بني اس اسرائيل
بما
صبروا
ودمرنا ما كان يصنع فرعون وقومه وما كانوا
يعرشون وجاوزنا ببني اسرائ ال البحر فاتوا
على قوم يعكفون على اصنام
لهم وجاوزنا ببني
اسرائيل البحر فاتوا على قوم يعكفون على
اصنام لهم قالوا يا موسى اجعل لنا الها
كما لهم الهه قال
انكم قوم
تجهلون ان
هؤلاء متبر ما هم
فيه
وباطل ما كانوا يعملون
قال غير الله ابغيكم
الها وهو فضلكم على
العالمين واذ
انجيناكم من ال فرعون
يسومونكم سوء
العذاب
العذاب يقتلون
ابناءكم
ويستحيون
نساءكم وفي
ذلكم
بلاء من ربكم
عظيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏sp
استقيم واعتدل
استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وواعدنا موسى ثلاثين ليله واتممناها
بعشر فتم ميقات ربه اربعين
ليله وق قال موسى لاخيه هارون اخلفني في
قومي واصلح ولا تتبع سبيل
المفسدين ولما
جاء موسى لميقاتنا وكلمه ربه قال رب ارني
انظر
اليك قال لن تراني ولكن انظر الى الجبل
فان استقر مكانه فسوف
فتراني فلما تجلى ربه للجبل جعله دكا وخر
موسى
صعقا فلما افاق قال سبحانك تبت اليك وانا
اول
المؤمنين قال يا موسى اني اصطفيتك على
الناس برسالاتي
وبكلامي فخذ ما اتيتك وكن من
الشاكرين وكتبنا له في الالواح من كل شيء
موعظه وتفصيلا لكل شيء فخذها بقوه وامر
اهلك وامر قومك ياخذوا
باحسنها ساريكم دار
الفاسقين ساصرف عن اياتي الذين يتكبرون في
الارض بغير الحق وان يروا كل ايه لا
يؤمنوا بها وان يروا سبيل الرشد لا يتخذوه
سبيلا وان يروا سبيل الغي يتخذوه
سبيلا ذلك
بانهم كذبوا
باياتنا وكانوا عنها غافلين
والذين كذبوا باياتنا
ولقاء الاخره حبطت
اعمالهم هل يجزون الا ما كانوا
يعملون هل يجزون الا ما كان ما كانوا
يعملون واتخذ قوم موسى من بعده من حلي م
عجلا جسدا له
خوار الم يروا انه لا يكلمهم ولا يهديهم
سبيلا اتخذوه وكانوا ظالمين ولما سقط في
ايديهم وراوا انهم قد
ضلوا قالوا لئن لم يرحمنا ربنا ويغفر لنا
قالوا لئن لم يرحمنا ربنا ويغفر لنا
لنكونن من
الخاسرين ولما رجع موسى الى قومه غضبان
اسفا قال يا قوم بئس ما خلفتموني من بعدي
اعجلتم
اعجلتم امر ربكم واخذ والقى الالواح واخذ
براس اخيه يجره اليه قال ابن ام ان القوم
استضعفوني وكادوا يقتلونني
فلا تشمت بي
الاعداء ولا تجعلني مع القوم
الظالمين قال رب اغفر لي ولاخي
وارحمنا وارحمنا وان
انت خير وانت ارحم
الراحمين قال رب اغفر لي ولاخي وادخلنا في
رحمتك وانت ارحم
الراحمين ان الذين اتخذوا العجل سينالهم
غضب من ربهم وذله
وذله في الحياه الدنيا وكذلك نجزي المفتر
والذين عملوا السيئات ثم تابوا من بعدها
وامنوا ان ربك من بعدها لغفور رحيم واختار
موسى قومه سبعين رجلا
لميقاتنا ولما سكت عن موسى الغضب اخذ
الواح وفي نسختها هدى ورحمه للذين هم
لربهم
يرهبون واختار موسى قوم واختار موسى قومه
سبعين رجلا
لميقاتنا
فلما اخذتهم الرجفه قال رب لو شئت قال رب
لو شئت
اهلكتهم من قبل
اياي اتهلكنا بما فعل
السفهاء
منا ان هي الا فتنتك تضل بها من
تشاء وتهدي بها من
تشاء انت ولينا فاغفر لنا
وارحمنا وانت
خير
الغافرين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العال
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واكتب لنا في هذه الدنيا حسن
وفي الاخره انا هدنا اليك قال عذابي اصيب
به من
اشاء ورحمتي وسعت كل شيء فساكتبها
للذين يتقون ويؤتون الزكاه والذين هم
باياتنا
يؤمنون الذين يتبعون الرسول النبي الام
امي الذي يجدونه مكتوبا عندهم في التوراه
والانجيل يامرهم بالمعروف وينهاهم عن
وينهاهم يامرهم بالمعروف وينهاهم عن
المنكر
ويحرم ويحل لهم الطيبات ويحرم عليهم
الخبائث ويضع عنهم اصرهم والاغلال التي
كانت عليهم فالذين امنوا به وعزروه ونصروه
واتبعوا النور الذي انزل
معه واتبعوا النور الذي انزل معه
اولئك هم
المفلحون قل يا ايها الناس اني رسول الله
اليكم
جميعا الذي له ملك السماوات والارض لا اله
الا هو يحيي
ويميت فامنوا بالله
ورسوله نبي الامي الذي يؤمن
بالله الذي يؤمن بالله
وكلماته واتبعوه
لعلكم تهتدون
ومن ومن قوم موسى امه يهدون الى الحق وبه
يعدلون ومن قوم موسى امه يهدون بالحق وبه
يعدلون
وقطعناهم اثنتي عشره اسباطا امما واوحينا
الى موسى اذ استسقاه قومه ان اضرب بعصاك
الحبحر ان اضرب بعصاك الحجر فانبجست منه
اثنتا عشره عينا قد علم كل اناس مشربهم
وظللنا عليهم الغمام
وانزلنا
وانزلنا عليهم وظللنا عليهم الغمام
وانزلنا عليهم من
والسلوى كلوا من طيبات ما
رزقناكم وما ظلمونا ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون واذ قيل لهم ادخلوا هذه القريه
وكلوا منها حيث شئتم
وقول واذ قيل لهم اسكنوا هذه القريه وكلوا
منها حيث شئتم وادخلوا وقولوا حطه وقولوا
حطه وادخلوا الباب
سجدا نغفر لكم
خطيئاتكم سنزيد
المحسنين فبدل الذين ظلموا قولا غير الذي
قيل لهم فارسلنا عليهم رجزا من السماء
فارسلنا عليهم رجزا من
السماء بما كانوا
يظلمون واسالهم عن القريه التي كانت حاضره
البحر اذ يعدون في السبت اذ تاتيهم
حيتانهم
شرعا ويوم لا يسبتون لا
تاتيهم واسالهم عن القريه التي كان حاضره
البحر اذ يعدون
في واسالهم عن القريه التي كانت حاضره
البحر اذ يعدون في السبت اذ تاتيهم
حيتانهم
شرعا واسالهم عن القريه التي كانت حاضره
السب حاضره البحر اذ يعدون في السبت اذ
تاتيهم حيتانهم يوم سبت م سرعا ويوم لا
يسبتون لا
تاتيهم كذلك
نبلوهم بما كانوا
يفسقون واذ قالت امه لم تعظون قوما الله
مهلكهم او معذبهم عذابا
شديدا قالوا معذره الى ربكم ولعلهم يرجعون
فلما نسو مانه عنه اخذ نجينا الذين كانوا
ينهون فلما نسوا مانه ذكروا به
فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به انجينا الذين ينهون
عن السوء
واخذنا واخذنا الذين كذبوا باياتنا
واخذنا الذين ظلموا بعذاب
بيس بما كانوا
يفسقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اك ر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى
اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن تبع باحسان ال يوم
الدين اما بعد ان شاء الله
الله سبحانه وتالى البقره وما تقم انفسكم
خير تجدوا عند
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله حديث رول صلى
عل الصدقه تفي الخطيئه كما يفي ال الماء
النار
صدقه
out
short like
[Silence]
‏mindful
gener ex رول الله صل الله عليه
ومشه
ضي
حث
and would and and
and سبحان iest
‏you know that i don't know most of you
heard or not there was a
sugg
صلس may a
dat may a of dat may
some صل
عل
days fire
in there nothing to make there to
eat and just
[Silence]
‏you came down one dat a and dat was
sock on the inner of
dat was
wase so we have be refle refle on this
time this time we have toit
‏how not any don't
[Silence]
take ‏doesn't me take si ble
and as so in mon have be very very very
mindful of and gener as as what you and
concl
with ابكر ض
[Silence]
‏own
every عم
ض
ر
given the
qu
way لل سبحانه وتالى اللهب
الله سبحانه
وتالى المتصدقين اللال
[Silence]
‏nothing you know but that's it that's
the
idea if i have ان الله let me fin of علي
ض hin are not feeling well so they make
in to fast so they can and fas consecu
days
l the fast consecutive days
عل of
the the oats and stuff and make bre out
of
it sit down to
eat there
the open
it i haven all can i
have pi
up all
[Silence]
‏second
عل
[Silence]
ضي let one
‏on
the i
hav what do you think did the third
day they told we haven days either is
that what
did that's a fast
[Silence]
‏what
don't
something not ching our
time per per
[Silence]
‏present ي مق
م present
رول الله صل الله عليه
وسم ان شاء اللهن الله تالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
[Silence]
اللهه الله سبحانه
وتالى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب
القنا عذاب جهنم شت المحنا شسح الدجال
ربنا تقبل منا انك السميع العليم وتب علب
الرحيمى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحم ال اللهم امين اللهم اللهم
امين
[Silence]
استووا
واعتدلوا استووا
الله
اكبر بسم الله
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ تاذن ربك
ليبعثن عليهم الى يوم القيامه من يسومهم
سوء العذاب
ان ربك لسريع العقاب وانه لغفور
رحيم واذ قالت امه منهم لم تعظون قوما
الله مهلكهم او معذبهم عذابا شديدا قالوا
معذره الى ربكم ولعلهم
يتقون فلما فلما فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به
انجينا الذين ينهون عن السوء
واخذنا واخذنا الذين ظلموا بعذاب بئيس بما
كانوا
يفسقون فلما عتوا عمانه عنه قلنا لهم
كونوا قرده
خاسئين واذ تاذن ربك
ليبعثن عليهم الى يوم القيامه من يسومهم
سوء العذاب
ان ربك لسريع العقاب وانه لغفور رحيم
وقطعناهم في الارض امما منهم الصالحون
ومنهم دون ذلك
وبلوناهم بالحسنات والسيئات لعلهم
يرجعون فخلف من بعدهم خلف ورثوا
الكتاب ورثوا الكتاب ياخذون عرض هذا
الادنى ويقولون سيغفر لنا وان ياتهم
عرض مثله
ياخذوه الم يؤخذ عليهم ميثاق الكتاب الا
يقولوا على الله الا الحق ودرسوا ما فيه
والدار الاخره خير للذين يتقون افلا
تعقلون
والذين يمسكون بالكتاب واقاموا الصلاه انا
لا نضيع اجر
المصلحين واذ نتقنا الجبل فوقهم كانه ظله
وظنوا انه واقع بهم خذوا ما اتيناكم
بقوه واذكروا ما فيه لعلكم
تتقون واذ اخذ ربك من بني ادم من ظهورهم
ذريتهم واشهدهم على انفسهم الست
بربكم قالوا بلى شهدنا ان تقولوا يوم
القيامه انا كنا عن هذا
غافلين او تقولوا انما اشرك
اباؤنا من قبل وكنا ذريه من من بعدهم
افتهلكنا بما فعل
المبطلون وكذلك نفصل الايات ولعلهم
يرجعون واتل عليهم نبا الذي اتيناه اياتنا
فانسلخ منها فكان من
الغاوين واتل عليهم نبا الذي اتيناه
اياتنا
فانسلخ منها فاتبعه الشيطان فكان من
الغاوين ولو شئنا لرفعناه بها
ولكنه اخلد الى الارض واتبع
هواه فمثله كمثل الكلب ان تحمل عليه يلهث
او تتركه
يلهث ذلك مثل القوم الذين كذبوا باياتنا
فاقصص القصص لعلهم
يتفكرون ساء مثلا القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا وانفسهم كانوا
يظلمون من يهدي الله فهو المهتدي ومن يضلل
فاولئك هم
الخاسرون ولقد ذرانا لجهنم
كثيرا من الجن
والانس لهم قلوب لا يفقهون بها ولهم اعين
لا يبصرون بها ولهم اذان لا يسمعون بها
اولئك كالانعام بل هم اضل اولئك هم
الغافلون ولله الاسماء الحسنى فادعوه بها
وذروا الذين يلحدون في
اسمائه سيجزون ما كانوا
يعملون وممن خلقنا اممه يهدون بالحق وبه
يعدلون والذين كذبوا باياتنا سنستدرجهم من
حيث لا يعلمون واملي لهم ان كيدي
متين اولم يتفكروا ما بصاحبهم من
جنه ان هو الا نذير
مبين اولم
ينظروا في ملكوت السماوات والارض وما خلق
الله من
شيء وان عسى ان يكون قد اقترب
اجلهم فباي حديث بعده
يؤمنون من يضلل الله فلا هادي له ويذرهم
في طغيانهم
يعمهون يسالونك عن الساعه ايان مرساها قل
قل علم قل انما علمها عند ربي لا يجليها
لوقتها الا هو ثقلت في السماوات والارض لا
تاتيكم الا بغته يسالونك كانك حفي عنها قل
انما علمها عند الله ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون قل لا املك لنفسي نفعا ولا ضرا الا
ما شاء
الله ولو كنت اعلم الغيب لاستكثرت من
الخير وما مسني
السوء ان انا الا نذير وبشير لقوم
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
هو الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وجعل منها
زوجها ليسكن اليها فلما تغشاها حملت حملا
خفيفا فمرت به فلما اثقلت دعو الله ربهما
لئن اتيتنا صالحا
لنكونن من الشاكرين
فلما اتاهما صالحا جعلا له شركاء فيما
اتاهما فتعالى الله عما
يشركون ايشركون ما لا يخلق شيئا وهم
يخلقون ولا يستطيعون لهم نصرا ولا انفسهم
ينصرون وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا اتبعوهم
سواء عليكم ادعوتموهم ام انتم
صامتون ان الذين تدعون من دون الله عباد
امثالكم فادعوهم
فليستجيبوا لكم ان كنتم
صادقين الهم ارجل يمشون بها ام لهم ايد
يبطشون بها ام لهم اعين يبصرون بها ام لهم
اذان يسمعون بها قل ادعوا
شركاءكم ثم كيدون فلا
تنظرون ان ولي الله الذي نزل الكتاب وهو
يتولى
الصالحين والذين تدعون من دونه لا
يستطيعون نصركم ولا انفسهم
ينصرون وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا
يسمعوا وان وتراهم ينظرون اليك وهم لا
يبصرون خذ العفو وامر بالعرف واعرض عن
الجاهلين واما
ينزغنك من الشيطان نزغ فاستعذ
بالله انه سميع عليم
ان الذين اتقوا اذا مسهم طائف من الشيطان
تذكروا فاذا هم
مبصرون واخوانهم يمدونهم في الغي ثم لا
يقصرون واذا لم تاتهم بايه قالوا لولا
اجتبيتها قل انما اتبع ما يوحى الي من ربي
هذا بصا
من ربكم وهدى ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون واذا قرئ القران فاستمعوا له
وانصتوا لعلكم ترحمون واذكر ربك في نفسك
تضرعا
وخيفه ودون الجهر من القول بالغدو
والاصال بالغدو والاصال ولا تكن من
غافلين ان الذين عند ربك لا يستكبرون عن
عبادته
ويسبحونه
ويسبحونه وله
يسجدون الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يسالونك عن الانفال قل الانفال لله
والرسول فاتقوا الله واصلحوا ذات بينكم
واطيعوا الله ورسوله ان كنتم مؤمنين
انما المؤمنون الذين اذا ذكر الله وجلت
قلوبهم واذا تليت عليهم اياته زادتهم
ايمانا وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون الذين يقيمون الصلاه ومما رزقناهم
ينفقون
اولئك هم المؤمنون حقا لهم درجات عن عند
ربهم ومغفره ورزق
كريم
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا صراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين كما اخرجك ربك من بيتك بالحق وان يقا
من المؤمنين
لكارهون يجادلونك في الحق بعد ما تبين
كانما يساقون الى الموت وهم
ينظرون واذ يعدكم الله احدى
الطائفتين انها لكم وتودون ان غير ذات
الشوكه تكون لكم ويريد الله ان يحق الحق
بكلماته ويقطع دابر
الكافرين ليحق الحق ويبطل الباطل ولو كره
المجرمون اذ تستغيثون ربكم فاستجاب لكم
اني
ممدكم بالف من الملائكه مردفين وما جعله
الله الا بشرى ولتطمئن به قلوبكم وما
النصر الا من عن عند
الله ان الله عزيز
حكيم اذ يغشيكم النعاس امنه منه وينزل
عليكم من السماء ماء
ليطهركم
به
ليطهركم به ويذهب عنكم رجز الشيطان وليربط
على قلوبكم ويثبت به الاقدام
اذ يوحي ربك الى الملائكه اني معكم فثبتوا
الذين امنوا سالقي في قلوب الذين كفروا
الرعب فاضربوا فوق الاعناق واضربوا منهم
كل
بنان ذلك بانهم
شاقوا الله ورسوله ومن يشاقق الله ورسوله
ان الله شديد
العقاب ذلكم فذوقوه وان للكافرين عذاب
النار يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم
الذين كفروا زحفا فلا تولوهم
الادبار ومن يولهم يومئذ دبره الا متحرفا
لقتال او متح زا الى فئه فقد باء بغضب من
الله وماواه
جهنم وماواه جهنم وبئس
المصير فلم تقتلوهم ولكن الله قتلهم وما
رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى وليبلي
المؤمنين منه بلاء حسنا ان ان الله سميع
عليم ذلكم وان الله موهن كيد
الكافرين ان تستفتحوا فقد جاءكم الفتح وان
تنهوا فهو خير لكم وان تعودوا نعد ولن
تغني عنكم فئتكم شيئا ولو كثرت وان الله
مع
المؤمنين الله
اكب سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله ورسوله
ولا تولوا عنه وانتم
معرضون يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
ورسوله ولا تولوا عنه وانتم
تسمعون ولا تكونوا كالذين قالوا سمعنا وهم
لا
يسمعون ان شر الدواب
عند الله الصم البكم الذين لا
يعقلون ولو علم الله فيهم خيرا لاسمعهم
ولو اسمعهم لتولوا وهم
معرضون يا ايها الذين امنوا استجيبوا لله
وللرسول اذا دعاكم لما يحييكم واعلموا ان
الله حول بين المرء وقلبه وانه اليه
تحشرون واتقوا فتنه لا تصيبن الذين ظلموا
منكم
خاصه واعلموا ان الله شديد
العقاب واذكروا اذ انتم قليل مستضعفون في
الارض تخافون ان يتخطفكم الناس
اواكم فاوا وايدكم بنصره ورزقكم من
الطيبات لعلكم
تشكرون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تخونوا لا
تخونوا الله والرسول وتخونوا اماناتكم
وانتم
تعلمون واعلموا انما اموالكم واولادكم
فتنه وان الله عنده اجر
عظيم يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تتقوا الله
يجعل لكم
فرقانا ويكفر عنكم سيئاتكم ويغفر لكم
والله ذو الفضل
العظيم واذ يمكر بك الذين كفروا ليثبتوك
او يقتلوك او
يخرجوك ويمكرون ويمكر الله والله خير ال
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا قالوا قد سمعنا لو
نشاء لقلنا مثل هذا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين واذ قالوا اللهم ان كان هذا هو
الحق من عندك فامطر علينا حجاره من السماء
او ائتنا بعذاب
اليم وما كان الله ليعذبهم وانت فيهم وما
كان الله معذبهم وهم
يستغفرون وما لهم الا يعذبهم الله وهم
يصدون عن المسجد الحرام وما كانوا
اولياءه ان
اولياؤه الا المتقون ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
وما كان صلاتهم عند البيت الا
مكاء وتصديه فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون ان الذين كفروا ينفقون اموالهم
ليصدوا عن سبيل
الله فسينفقونها
ثم تكون عليهم حسره ثم يغلبون
والذين كفروا الى جهنم
يحشرون ليميز الله الخبيث من الطيب ويجعل
الخبيث بعضه على بعض فيركمه
جميعا فيركمه جميعا فيجعله في
جهنم اولئك هم
الخاسرون قل للذين كفروا ان ينتهوا يغفر
لهم ما قد سلف وان يعودوا فقد مضت سنه
الاولين وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه ويكون
الدين كله
لله فان انتهوا فان الله بما يعملون
بصير وان تولوا فاعلموا ان الله
مولاكم نعم المولى ونعم النصير
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الشفع
والوتر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرح الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا في الصحف الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حميده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا جاء نصر الله والفتح ورايت الناس
يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملء السماوات وملء الارض وملء
ما بينهما ومل ما شئت من شيء بعد احق ما
قال العبد و كلنا لك عبد اللهم لا مانع
لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما منعت ولا ينفع ذا
الجد منك الجد اللهم اهدنا في من هديت
وعافنا في من عافيت وتولنا في من توليت
وبارك اللهم لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي
بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت لك الحمد يا ربنا اللهم انا نسالك
موجبات رحمتك
وعزائم مغفرتك والغنيمه من كل بر والسلامه
من كل اثم والفوز بالجنه والنجاه من النار
يا عزيز يا غفار
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق
رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار برحمتك يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا كلها دقها
وجلها اولها واخرها علانيتها وسرها ما
علمنا منها وما لم نعلم برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين رب اغفر وارحم واعف وتكرم وتجاوز
عما تعلم انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك انت
الله الاعز الاكرم انك انت الله الاعز
الاكرم اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر يا رب
العالمين اكتب لنا فيها قياما وصياما يا
رب العالمين اللهم بلغ غنا ليله القدر يا
رب العالمين اكتب لنا قيامها وقراءه
القران فيها يا رب العالمين اللهم تقبل
منا الصيام والقيام وتقبل منا قراءه
القران وتقبل منا صالح
الاعمال برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين سبحان
ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب العالمين امين وصل
اللهم وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه
اجمعين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله ‏ja